welcome to this video this is about the
round 10 game candidates tournament
between kayaking and and draken quickly
summing up both players standing in the
tournament before the game cockiness now
on fifty percent after two wins he's
really coming back from the dead here
and is in a way one of the more
dangerous players for for Ireland so
chances simply because he simply plays
am honored later in the tournament and
yeah he has he has some [ __ ] he has the
momentum at least and then Drake in now
is on minus one okay let's see we get a
Sicilian and again this time on over
move order back in United's III now a
six yeah I I looked this up and raking
had only played this twice in his career
this opening and it's been years ago so
not something that would be a high on
kayak insist in terms of what to prepare
for the specific game he now came up
with a wither absent sideline took on c6
which is not a sidelines one of the
options at white hairs but after this he
played the move Queen to d3 which looks
a bit odd at first bringing the Queen
out so early but it turned out to my
surprise that and this is some plate
well not very often but this has been
played by kayak in earlier in in more
than one game actually um and we see
later on how this this earlier games
relate to to this one yeah what is the
idea of Queen d3 yeah well idea is that
why does getting the Queen over to the
King side where it fulfills quite a
useful role pressurizing g7 for example
and ya can be can be threatening to
blacks King in the long run um this
capture on c6 by the way is very only
very rarely a good idea and the Sicilian
if you look at this it is normally
believed that the capture is
strengthening a black center and
therefore should be avoided however in
this specific case I'm black has played
the moose a 7 a-6 which in this ensuing
structure with the capture and b.tech
see which is almost a lost temple like
really does not want to play a six in
the structure that he has to or he has
done so before and only after that white
took him one reason why this is a viable
line is also that white gets a very
quick development the normal move from
instead of Queen d3 is actually Bishop
d3 and very often it's quick Castle
screen f 3 b3 Bishop b2 very quick
development and quite interesting play
very often black plays d5 later and
white moves the night and plays c4
against that attacking the center it's
actually quite a quite a good line for
white not not like brilliant but very
much playable yeah well this is
interesting as well and on Drake in
plate Queen to see seven which is almost
directly um yeah get to fight the Queen
g3 idea and you played this quickly yeah
Queen g3 anyway otherwise it does not
really make much sense this Queen III
move yeah black must capture yeah I'm
just uh yeah this is giving away g7 so
you basically need to capture and now we
went 45 yeah so what what to say about
this end game is this isn't this a very
toothless way to play as white
yeah I'm not sure I mean there there are
certainly more aggressive ways to play
with the white pieces but the white
position is maybe am very slightly more
comfortable because you have some scope
for Europe this double porn is not the
disadvantage of course it's just helping
white to get the rook activated
immediately and very often this GG poor
means that you can actually use this
porn and we see this immediately
kayaking is playing a g4 yeah what is
the purpose g4 intends to kick a night
that will appear on f6 would appear on a
fix it didn't right now let's say let's
say nine f6 just for argument's sake
then you can very much consider g5 now
like that TI even Luke h4 which shows
very nicely why this formation with a
double porn and the open H file can be
an interesting way to play white will
get this back just for argument's sake
let's put put moves on the border to
illustrate my point here you can easily
imagine the loop coming over to a for
putting pressure on a six why does is
really slightly better him so this is
why Knight f6 was avoided he played
rugby aid which seems like a really good
move that keeps an eye on the B to pawn
and makes it difficult for y to develop
the queenside g5 feel quite logical
keeping those squares under control so
Knight f6 cannot be played easily yeah
here I was at this point I was entering
the the live broadcast and watching a
bit of that and it was quite funny to
hit quite funny to see that in this
position here they have a commentating
duo of Grandmaster and Victoria's maleta
very strong female player she's been on
2500
for for very long time and the the male
commentator is peter huynh and yields
and very strong GM from denmark
somewhere around to 650 GM and them
they're married they're couple so very
very unique situation and it was quite
funny that Victoria here suggested the
move f6 and you could visibly see in the
picture that peter huynh the news and
were thinking that this is not a good
move but he couldn't really tell tell
them the wife won't care that's not a
good move and you some very polite
listen I don't really think this is not
really and what I sort of agreed that
looked a bit strange to me to play of
6cm and one of course just quickly
afterwards and drinking was playing f6
which was there quite quite funny and
it's it's it's an okay move I mean only
my initial idea was then why why would
you play of six year but it's a in fact
I think a good idea this g5 porn is
quite an annoyance and getting rid of it
as service makes some sense yeah enter
white basically must take there is not
much else if you consider black takes
they would this would hang a little bit
to pawn so let's say for argument's sake
this kind of thing well maybe you could
make this work technically but why would
you give up the point is there's no
doesn't make more sense so he took and
now Knight f6 yeah and this has at least
helped like a bit with developing yeah
and now in this position we we see a
novelty yes this has been played before
that in a game kayaking mmhmm yeah note
against Mammadyarov so there is a
history of this line in this game from
2009 he would play Bishop to d3
certainly am sensible kings
um here he went for a five which is
maybe a bit more testing for black him
hard to tell but it grep space and yeah
leads to a really complicated type of
position a form and now a dragon plate
night to see five yeah this M is
certainly a good plan I mean the plan
associated with that you will see in a
couple of moves um it's interesting to
see that the computer here suggests the
very aggressive move g5 and in fact this
is an idea it's not it's not out of this
world what I find remarkable though that
the computer even after g3 yeah of
course this is the basic idea you would
love to get the central pawn um after g3
which was probably the best move the
computer even wants to push with age
five and tending h form which looks
somewhat crazy to me but it's may be
playable I mean why not it's not like
the black king is in big danger here or
anything you far away from being
attacked and why not attack the pawn
chain and this probably was a valid way
to play but 95 is also i'm very logical
if you look at what happens afterwards
yeah be three on our first look actually
i'm sorry certainly also a good move to
to activate on the on the third-ranked
giving this Ruxin scope a 5 p-3 yeah get
you need to do this at some stage and
then Bishop a six this was the idea
behind the night c5 movie wanted to go
night see 585 bishop asics get rid of
this problematic c8 bishop and this is
certainly a strategically well-founded
decision yeah
quite exchange and now put a night on a
form young why to a for this has
multiple ideas white wants to attack the
a5 pawn mostly this is the main reason
and overnight comes to c5 you're ready
to take it yeah this was now played band
Reagan and I'm not one hundred percent
sure if this is such a great idea but um
I'm not sure what you should do actually
maybe I'm maybe a slow moves like let's
say we should pair 95 actually it's also
something that you could try that's the
the keep it keep it simple approach to
just exchange em what is always a slight
concern for black in this type of
position is that the a porn could could
become quit become weak yeah it can
easily be attacked by the bishop and
yeah it's it slightly slightly
uncomfortable not like great problems
but this is the one of the points that
white can still play for in fact after
look before here okay I can play
immediately bishop d 2 which will get
pressure on the pawn um here I think he
could have tried a three and I think
this would have been slightly more
testing and also it contains a little
trap of course relatively easy to see
trap I admit that now rupees for check
the this is a bit of a pseudo active
move why just place here and now he
threatens 93 and winning in exchange
like that and the look is strapped it's
actually already trapped here cannot
save it anymore unless you play the
really hideous move deform just terrible
um flight goes night b2 and comes to
this fantastic squares which is so
strategically really terrible i mean 85
is weak everything's week and this rook
is still in a funny place so okay as i
mentioned it's easy to see that rookie
fries rubbish so black master must
promptly returned here and now Bishop to
e2 yeah and this is some very comparable
to the game um only difference is that
here the rook is passive not only for
and black is not was not able to get the
bishop out in the game let's go get this
checked and now he got got in Bishop to
b4 white one doesn't want does not want
to trade when c3 and now Bishop to a
3-gallon rookie 1gen rid of this active
rook and castles yeah not sure about
castle 3d again there was the
opportunity to to get stuff exchanged
maybe this wasn't easy I defense I'm not
one hundred percent sure castles King to
and age 6 yeah and now we come to
something that I don't really understand
i'm quite quite frank here with you um
rook g3 was now played king to f7 age
three mm-hmm King g6 check
yeah check this will really plate and
now draw and I don't really understand
this why isn't white playing on here I
mean I understand that right is not
having a fantastically great advantage
but white certainly has somewhat of a
slight advantage simply because of
better space with e5 and F for being
played a 5 is a potential weakness and
well you have ways to continue there's
no need really to draw here if you look
at this I mean here at any any point
basically you can play let's say g3 you
can play g4 and then simply play on and
try to make something out of that but it
didn't happen they just agree to a draw
it from and Drake in this perspective I
can actually understand he's got black
and well its got minus one no not really
like he's in big contention in this
tournament while kayaking has just won
two games and really has chances still
even being on fifty percent it's very
easy if you look at this game if you if
you want to imagine a scenario for him
how he can qualify this very easy you
just needs to win this game which you
didn't even try at the end and then he
needs to beat are not with white I mean
not so easy but this is all right that's
it then he would go on to plus two are
not lose this one he would have the
better tie break due to the win in the
divisional game so it's not like now he
needs a win he needs one win besides the
game against islands which he if he
wants to qualify has to win anyway not
that it is easy or anything but well you
need to do something in order to earn
the spot and so I don't really
understand why he didn't continue I
don't really see any losing chances for
white and you can just play on without
any particular risk or anything well i'm
not sure i didn't i didn't see the
postgame press conference so maybe there
was some
planation for that well objectively
speaking white is certainly not much
better but still I can guarantee you if
you would set up a team tournament with
this position and you give Magnus cards
and the white pieces and under aching
the black pieces and raking wouldn't
score so many points from that this
would be an easy 73 win or seven and a
half win and I'm really really sure
about that you just you just need to
grind on and on and set problems and if
you give those positions just just allow
a draw then I don't really know what
what the point is he needs to win one
more game and this is a good at good a
chance as any so I'm not really sure
what the rationale was behind her
allowing this draw here well i'm not
saying why this is great but why not
just continue you can really easily do
that um let's mention g4 you can try to
get the rook over and play c4 and
whatever there are there are some ideas
to do and really there's no risk it's
not like I would understand if there was
some direct risk involved because a loss
on the other hand would be very very
hard to to compensate but how are you
going to lose this position that's why I
really don't see it okay I don't know
you you never know what what are you
very often don't know what the
background of some of those games is
maybe he was just feeling bad from from
from a health perspective or whatever
you never know but if I don't really
from if there isn't anything special
going on in the background I really
don't understand why this game wasn't
continued from the white player all
right I hope you still enjoyed the
coverage thanks for watching